guy looks like an Incredible Hulk you'll
see when somebody's on juice that's not
what the video look like you know it's a
big factor for that Pat he's not taking
any vaccines here's a party you have to
realize people think like if you choose
listen you juice you still have to go to
the gym four or five times a week look
at this guy yeah that doesn't look like
a juicer's body though a juicer's body
you know maybe trt maybe some of that
stuff but I don't know about all the
other stuff he's looking good and he's
got policies and he's you know
challenging people take a look at this
at first people thought this was a spoof
they didn't know it was him where is
this so how much is this how much is
this 45 for the bar it's not a lot of
weight he's inclining he's inclining 105
right there for 115 right there that's
not a lot of weight 115 is not a lot
that looks like a 25 and a 10. unless if
it's a 35 and a 10 definitely not a 45
the 45 is right next to it looks more
like a 25 and a 10. tell you what he is
the most jacked presidential candidate
we've ever in the Democratic Party Guys
69 years old he's doing